I'm gonna give you Mark Cuban rule
number one and whenever you forget this
rule you're already out of business
you don't need to have this humongous
GPA and all astir [ __ ] which you need is
the one thing I talked to my book if I
could go back and you could only give me
one skill to begin with and I had to
build from all of it I can tell you for
sure what it would be for me want to be
happy
build a life not just the business
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the five skills that will
make you rich okay let's kick it off
with skill number one persuade people
with Edie my life if I could go back and
you could only give me one skill to
begin with and I had to build from all
of it I can tell you for sure what it
would be for me and that would be the
ability to influence so it's the ability
to persuade people without that skill
set the vast majority of my wealth does
not exist if you can't persuade people
if you can't influence people to make
decisions that are in their own best
interest but that also grow your
business your brand your company your
net worth
you can't ever become successful one
thing that everybody I know that's a
leader and everything they do can do is
persuade people now I watch people do
that in all different types of way some
do it through intimidation some through
do it through force some do it through
humor some do it through persuasive
strategies transfer of energy you name
it but all leaders can persuade all
successful people can get people to make
decisions in their own best interests
that also get them to participate with
their company it's the number one skill
that I see most people not spending the
most time on is their ability to
communicate their ability to persuade
people and because they're constantly
trying to go to a different course or
they think that somehow if their product
is good enough or they get the right
sales pitch that somehow they're gonna
win but the fact of the matter is you've
got to become a better person
skill number two learn how to sell with
Mark Cuban
I'm gonna give you Mark Cuban rule
number one and whenever you forget this
rule you're already out of business in
every business sales Cure's all has
anybody ever heard of a business that
had zero sales sales that was successful
doesn't happen yet a lot of people start
their business thinking I have a great
idea I'm gonna do this this is amazing
I'm gonna go raise money I just sold
this idea and then it comes back and
it's like okay you gotta sell that
product or you got to sell that service
that's the first main key to a
successful business when you're getting
ready to start
you have to answer that question also if
you want to learn how to have more
confidence check by 250 for confident
series it's free the link is in the
description below the minute you begin
to get external in your life worrying
about what other people think about you
right you vote you've lost all control
you can it never fills you up I've
always been passionate some people
thought you know it's a it's more OCD
than anything else everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today skill number 3 have a brutal
work ethic with David Goggins you don't
need to have this humongous GPA and all
astir [ __ ] what you need is the one
thing I talked on my book what's your
straight up brutal work ethic you have
to be willing to outwork everybody in
the world and that that that's the hard
part that's the hard part this isn't
like some five step process where you
can do these five steps you're gonna end
up with this magical world no I'm
basically teaching you how to callus
over your victims mentality I'm teaching
you how to like I did sixty seven
thousand pull-ups and training for the
pull-up record I was seriously calloused
in my hands to protect them what I'm
trying to do with people is teach them
how to find more themselves to where
they empower themselves I'm all about
the underdog
skill number four learn how to execute
with Kevin O'Leary
every entrepreneur I mean is very
passionate that's just part of the
equation I actually argue that what
matters most is executional skills every
entrepreneur is passionate everybody
that's as an entrepreneur is ready to
take that journey and go down that road
and that's great but the ones that are
still doing it three years later have
executional skills so that's what I
think matters above everything else I
meet lots of teams i fund lots of
companies I see lots of failure and lots
of successes the difference is men and
women primarily women these days that
can really execute that set goals tell
you what they are talk to you every
three months saying I achieve this goal
or I didn't and why and
me that's the building block of a
business there's nothing worse than
vision all day long
vision is easy execution is hard and
skill number five the last one before a
very special bonus clip is maximize high
income skills with Dan lock what do you
do if you don't want to be an
entrepreneur let me tell you about my
friend Juan now I'm known run for almost
ten years now he is one of the highest
paid photographer in my city it takes a
lot of different photos one of the most
expensive in my city now he doesn't have
a business he's simply a photographer
what ron has is a high income skill if
you follow my work you know I believe in
the power of having the high income
skill and I define high income skills
the skill that can make you a minimum
ten thousand dollars a month Thank You
month one hundred twenty thousand
dollars a year or more so ron has a high
income skill which is a high-end
photographer now he's a very frugal guy
remember back then you could have bought
a a place a house in Burnaby he's making
very good money but he bought a very
modest home not for a lot of money and
him and its wife and two kids living
there and he as he keeps making more and
more money he put aside and saved those
money and put it into real estate
he started off my smaller property
fixing them flipping them selling them
eventually moving into duplex bigger
bigger units and today after all these
years he owns over 200 units in
Vancouver now if you know Vancouver real
estate it is one of the most expensive
in the world so he owns apartment
buildings
he owns a commercial properties 200
doors
200 units he doesn't have a business he
is not a business owner
over the years he all he has is he has
developed botanical skills he has
maximized his high income skill and he
takes that money and put it into high
return investments in this case real
estate
that's it it's now worth tens of
millions of dollars
it's basically retired traveling with
the wife and traveling to all kinds of
countries just enjoy life because every
month it's got rental income coming in
right so I want you to think about you
don't need to be an entrepreneur to be
successful financially what you need to
absolutely that you need it's high
income skills now I've got a special
bonus clip with Jordan Peterson on how
to develop your communication skills
that I think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching a video to taking action
here we go question number one what high
income skill will you start to develop
this week number two what's the most
important thing you need to execute on
today and number three what will you do
to maintain your brutal work ethic I'm
incredibly nervous to talk in front of
you because you've got to be one of the
most formidable people that I've ever
heard of or ever listened to her ever
seen so my question is again you're one
of the best communicators that I've ever
listened to if I could be half as good
at you or at communicating as you are I
would be set how can I teach myself to
do that practice you know really like
well there's a couple of things is helps
to read a lot it really helps to write
so if you want to make yourself
articulate which is a very good idea
then not only should you read but you
should write down what you think and if
you can do that a little bit every day
15 minutes maybe you could steal 15
minutes and do it every day but if you
do that for 10 years you really
straighten out your thinking if you're
gonna speak effectively you have to know
way more than you're talking about you
know so if you this is often difficult
for beginning lectures at university
because they'll do a lecture on a topic
but they only know as much as they're
saying in the lecture and they get kind
of stuck to their notes because of it
but you want to know 10 times as much as
you are saying in the lecture and then
you can specify a stepping path through
it and elaborate with the other things
that you know but to do that you have to
do a lot of reading but you also have to
do a lot of reading because that's where
the synthesize that's where the
synthesizing comes so that's on the
input side and then on the output side
well there's some tricks techniques
let's say like if you're speaking in
front of a group you are not delivering
a talk to a group that's not what you're
doing the talk isn't a package thing
that you present to a group there isn't
a group there's a bunch of individuals
and you talk to them so when I talk to a
group I always talk to people one at a
time and that makes it easier to because
you know how to talk to a person it's
like can you talk to a thousand people
well probably not because it's too
intimidating but there isn't a thousand
people there there's a thousand
individuals and so you just look at an
individual and you say something and you
can tell if they're engaged they look
confused or they look interested or they
look angry or they look bored or maybe
they're asleep in which case you look at
someone else and they give you feedback
about how you're doing and so one thing
is to to have something to say yeah but
the next thing is pay attention to who
you're talking to
because unless you're very badly
socialized and that seems unlikely in
your case because you know you present
yourself at least moderately well you
know and well I mean I don't know you
very well but at first but on first
sight you know you're doing fine so the
probability that if you pay attention to
the individuals that you're talking to
that your natural wealth of social skill
will manifest itself is extremely high
and so you don't deliver a talk to an
audience that's a really bad way of
thinking about you're actually engaged
in a conversation with an audience even
if they're not talking they're nodding
and shifting position and you know
looking like this or and you can you can
pull all that in and and and use it to
govern the level at which you're
addressing the entire audience so
the last thing I would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well I
could bunch us that to some degree well
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent in everything you do than
to learn how to communicate I don't care
if you're gonna be a carpenter I mean
being a carpenter by the way is very
difficult especially if you're a good
carpenter but if you're good at
communicating as a carpenter you're like
ten times better as a carpenter so the
and this is something that the liberal
arts colleges I think him I don't know
if they've forgotten it but they don't
do a very good job of marketing it's
like what's the use of a bachelor's
degree a Bachelor of Arts it's like well
you can think you can write you can
speak you've read something it's like
the economic value that is incalculable
the people that I've watched in my life
who've been spectacularly successful are
they have skills clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful well that's
kind of like the definition of success
in life right you negotiate and you're
six it doesn't mean you win because if
you're a good negotiator if you're
really good negotiator everybody walks
away from the negotiation thrilled and
so then people line up to do things with
you so and that's all that's all
dependent on your ability to communicate
so practice
if you want to learn the 10 skills that
are hard to learn but will pay off
forever check out their video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
one of the things you would want to be
sure to do is whether you like it or not